[Música]
nós estamos vivendo uma época de guerra
contra o conhecimento século de
pesquisas científicas de descobertas a
terra plana um ataque às universidades
e nesta guerra eu vivo sendo apedrejado
mas eu quero contar uma história de
quando foi apedrejada de verdade essa
aqui é uma cidadezinha entre o irã eo
paquistão e no século passado eu
inventei de passar por lá ea gente
estava na rua um dia e os meninos
começaram a jogar pedras ea gente teve
que correr muito para não se machucar e
naquele pânico de porque eles estão
jogando pedra em nós
a gente descobriu que era porque a gente
era muito diferente
então o que é diferente gera medo eo
medo leva a agressão
nós éramos umas meninas coloridas a
gente não tinha burca não tinha roupa
preta então a gente botou todas as
roupas que a gente tinha e e a gente só
poderia parecer os extraterrestres para
eles então eu posso dizer literalmente
ignorância mata e quando eu tô dizendo
que ignorância mata não digo que eles
são ignorantes e a gente era civilizados
eu quero dizer que ambos os lados
ignoravam a outro
não só eles era completamente impensável
que nós éramos pra nós também era
completamente impensável aqueles 0
a gente também não sabia que a mulher
não podia andar sozinha na rua naquele
país
então pra combater isso existe um
empreendimento um grande conglomerado
que justamente se propõe a fazer essas
pontes entre as pessoas a cooperação
entre as pessoas ea diminuir a
ignorância do mundo pra que a gente
possa incluir cada vez mais gente no
nosso círculo de empatia ea boa notícia
é que esse grande conglomerado que dá
muito certo que a presente em todo o
brasil é propriedade de vocês vocês são
os donos
vocês são os donos de universidade
na verdade vocês são donos de 63
universidades federais 38 institutos
federais
existem também muitas universidades de
qualidade no brasil
comunitários por exemplo mas eu não vou
falar delas porque eu quero falar das
nossas e é sempre bom a gente saber como
é que andam os nossos negócios são as
universidades não apenas forma pessoas
elas forma as pessoas que vão construir
o país que vão pensar o país que vão
cuidar das outras pessoas e praça
universidade tem que ter qualidade nas
universidades públicas se destacam em
todos os rankings nacionais e
internacionais e as universidades
públicas fazem esmagadora maioria das
pesquisas no país
isso pode significar a cura de doenças
pode significar a tecnologia pode
significar técnicas para indústria
agropecuária eu queria chamar a atenção
de um detalhe tem coisas que a
universidade pública pesquisa que a
iniciativa privada nunca vai pesquisar
porque elas nunca vão dar lucro então
uma coisa que vai diminuir o custo que
vai ser muito barata como essa pesquisa
da unb que diminuiu a população de
mosquitos
ela nunca vai ser pesquisada pela
iniciativa privada por isso que a gente
precisa de investimento público em
pesquisa e isso é assim em todos os
países desenvolvidos do mundo
nossas pesquisas são tão x que aparece
até em seriado americano de medicina
as universidades têm laboratórios que
são navios
são fazendas aqui os agricultores
aproveitam os resultados de pesquisa
muito sério feito em agricultura para
desenvolver novas técnicas para produzir
alimentos mais saudáveis e e se essa
pesquisa por exemplo rende muito para
cada real investido em pesquisa
nesse caso específico isso rende muitos
reais
uma pesquisa também no que foi feito em
universidade pública pode significar uma
economia de milhões para o país um
tratamento mais barato a uma técnica
mais barata não só poupa milhões de
reais mas culpa milhares de vidas o que
é muito mais importante e tudo isso pode
se transformar em inovação pode se
transformar em produtos para depois é o
brasil não ser dependente de tecnologia
estrangeira e não ter que só vender os
nossos recursos
naturais além disso a universidade
pública devolve a extensão é o diálogo
da universidade com a sociedade e os
projetos são tão variados impacto
milhares de pessoas como por exemplo
produzir células em 3d para crianças com
deficiência visual poderão estudar
biologia ou o atendimento à saúde
as universidades públicas são
responsáveis por milhões de atendimentos
em todo o país só em porto alegre para
vocês terem uma idéia dois hospitais um
hospital universitário hospital de
ensino
os dois baseados basicamente na
universidade realizam milhares de
procedimentos e chama atenção o número
de transplantes quase todos os
transplantes no brasil são feitos nas
universidades as universidades preservam
o meio ambiente ensinando as crianças a
preservar o meio ambiente
as universidades trazem as pessoas para
dentro pra promover um envelhecimento
saudável para fazer atividade física
trazem as crianças para descobrir o
corpo humano e por falar em crianças não
existe dicotomia entre ensino básico e
ensino superior eo país precisa investir
mais em todos os níveis de educação e eu
queria contar a história de uma
professora maravilhosa do ensino básico
professora camila e pegoraro que fez à
tvi incrível idéia de ensinar filosofia
para as crianças
ela fez uma campanha para arrecadar
livros e foi assim que a gente se
conheceu
essas crianças são capazes de sites
incríveis por exemplo que verdade
histórica existente hoje você acha que
no futuro não será mais verdade eu acho
que no futuro os negros vão ter os
mesmos direitos que os brancos e não vai
ter tanto preconceito explica porque
para rigor não existe verdades eternas
porque o que no passado foi normal agora
no futuro pode ser um absurdo para
algumas pessoas tipo as mulheres não
poderem estudar e essas crianças que são
capazes de toda essa todo esse insight
filosófico onde estavam discutindo o que
elas queriam ser quando crescesse
e esse que é o marcelo que segundo a
professora camila é um génio de que iria
fazer um curso para ser lavador de carro
e ela disse mas meu filho pode ser um
engenheiro pode projetar carro pode
inventar carro pode projetar avião e
disse mais professora para isso tem que
pagar né
e aí ela contou na universidade pública
e isso acendeu brilhou o olho dele
porque acendeu uma possibilidade de
futuro que ele não conhecia e foi aí que
eles tiveram a idéia então de pedir
cartas nossas de quem estava na
universidade de gent que já tinha
passado pelo que marcelo tinha passado
tinha descoberto como chegar lá
professores técnicos e alunos nossos não
só os nossos alunos foram lá na escola
para contar suas histórias como também
as crianças vieram na universidade pra
visitar o museu de anatomia conhecer o
corpo humano
esses três enfermeiros maravilhosos aqui
que se formaram de dois deles
eles são os primeiros da sua família a
chegar no curso superior e uma delas
quando passou né
os pais de certo mas minha filha é muito
lindo passado no vestibular mas a gente
não tem dinheiro pra pagar
eles não tinham acesso à informação de
que a universidade pública gratuita e
acessível a todos e pra nós
representatividade importa
a gente está trabalhando muito para que
cada vez haja mais enfermeiros
maravilhosos como esses
hoje na universidade em todas as
universidades públicas nós temos 70% dos
alunos que têm renda familiar até 16
salários mínimos per capta 60% vêm da
escola pública 51% são negros 63% têm
mães que não têm curso superior
então a nossa função é acolher os sonhos
até daqueles meninos que um dia pedro e
jaru umas meninas a universidade muda a
história
nós temos a dona de casa que depois de
30 anos voltou a estudar
nós temos a mãe o filho na mesma
universidade em cursos diferentes nós
temos a menina com câncer que resolveu
se tornar médica para curar pessoas com
câncer
nós temos muitas histórias nós temos
pessoas que se encontraram que acolher
as diferenças que abriram os sonhos ea
universidade não muda só história de
quem estuda ou trabalha nela todo mundo
que vive em torno da universidade
principalmente nas cidades menores
se beneficia pelo desenvolvimento
econômico que a universidade trás
enquanto custa tudo isso custa bem menos
do que vocês pensam
esse é o cálculo do tcu de custo de um
estudante por mês na média de todas as
universidades federais
se a gente pegar o cálculo do mec é bem
mais do que isso
mas o mec considera também os
aposentados o que não é porque não é
considerado em nenhum outro lugar do
mundo nenhuma outra universidade do
mundo
mesmo assim isso fica bem abaixo da
média dos países não cdr e também
surpresa não é muito diferente do valor
de um aluno na creche e um dispêndio
público por aluno na creche e em um
município gaúcho
para vocês terem uma idéia da proporção
a gente tem uma receita de 3,5 trilhões
por ano dos quais 1,75 para o pagamento
da dívida 50 bilhões ao orçamento de
todas as universidades contando
inclusive o pagamento dos aposentados e
um orçamento que realmente chega na
universidade para ser administrada em
7,2 bilhões
é esse orçamento que está sendo
[Música]
diminuído e pra comparar o brasil vai
deixar de arrecadar esse ano e 376
bilhões em execução fiscal
muitas dessas coisas são projetos
interessantes mas a grande maioria são
coisas que não são nem fiscalizados e
são dívidas de empresas
então pra gente tem um pouco de
proporção bom mas agora esqueça tudo que
eu falei sobre custo e sobre o
rendimento da universidade você já toco
convencido de que o empreendimento de
vocês rende muito certo quando o país
está numa crise
onde é que a gente vai escolher investir
onde rende mais
mas eu quero contar uma história do
professor italiano no tio ordem ele diz
que se duas pessoas vão para a
universidade cada um com uma maçã quando
eles de maçã cada um vai sair da
universidade cada um como a maçã agora
se cada um for contra a universidade com
uma idéia
quando eles trocarem idéias cada um sai
com duas idéias então compartilhar
conhecimento é uma coisa que só aumenta
quando a gente compartilha por isso que
o conhecimento não pode seguir a lógica
do mercado
a gente não pode escolher abrir um curso
fechar um curso por causa da lógica do
mercado
a gente não pode analisar a universidade
com essa lógica porque tem coisas que
são impossíveis que a gente não pode
medir a mudança de vida o quanto a gente
pode mudar esses sonhos que eu falei
além disso existe um património
intangível da humanidade que é o
conhecimento acumulado e que as
universidades são as gordinhas desse
conhecimento pelo menos por enquanto
como foi na idade média
imaginem que um curso de grego ele nunca
vai ter procura suficiente pra valer a
pena é para o senhor mercado
mas imagine se não existe um curso de
grego imagina que em muitas cidades a
universidade ea dona dos principais
equipamentos culturais teatro cinema
arte então sem isso uma biblioteca a
biblioteca e nunca vai dar lucro mas sim
a gente seria muito mais pobre
então se é muito difícil a gente
calcular o valor intangível da
universidade em vidas
a quem interessa ignorância se a gente
está caminhando para uma sociedade do
conhecimento
a quem interessa que a gente não tenha
esse conhecimento
um país que não investe em educação é um
país que está condenado ao atraso e à
ignorância e tem muitas fake news sobre
a universidade sobre coisas que se
passam lá mas a gente tem muita verdade
para contrapor essa narrativa
todo mundo que conhece e que foi
impactado de alguma forma sabe que a
gente tem muita verdade
o poeta victor hugo falou na assembléia
constituinte 1848 o seguinte é
exatamente quando uma crise isso foca
uma nação que é preciso investir em
educação arte e cultura para evitar que
os jovens caiu no abismo da ignorância
por isso eu quero pedir a ajuda de vocês
espalhe essa ideia espalhem educação
espalhem o futuro
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]